good morning guys thanks Tony
pharmacists across the country you know
are raising alarm about the over
prescription of drugs that may help
treat the coronavirus recent data shows
chloroquine orders have spiked 3,000
percent in March and hydroxychloroquine
orders rode 200 rows 260 percent the FDA
has not approved these drugs for
treatment of the virus but doctors are
allowed to prescribe it our dr. Jon
LaPook who joins us from his New York
apartment John what do you know about
these drugs
hi Anthony well hydroxychloroquine is
used to treat autoimmune conditions like
rheumatoid arthritis and lupus but it's
too soon to say whether it really works
against kovat 19 that hasn't stopped
some people from prescribing it one
pharmacist said it's being widely
prescribed and that's leaving some
people who need it to control their
autoimmune disease is unable to get it
in the one consistent medication I've
been on since I was 15 daily is
hydroxychloroquine 44 year old Marissa
Tancharoen has been taking the drug
hydroxychloroquine since she was first
diagnosed her lupus has been severe
requiring several hospitalizations and
the drug is a cornerstone of her
treatment don't be you it's not a matter
of having it in your medicine cabinet
just in case you need it it's a matter
of your health yes it is a necessity
chloroquine is an anti-malaria drug and
it's less toxic derivative
hydroxychloroquine often creats
autoimmune diseases it's sold under the
brand name Plaquenil the CDC is
recommending patients who rely on
prescribed medication try to get an
extra supply but Anton's doctor tried
she called it in to my local pharmacy
she also called it in to the mail-order
pharmacy neither of those places can
fill it for me because it's so backward
thankfully I still have a month's supply
left in my cabinet but of course I don't
know how long this is going to last
I think it's gonna be very exciting I
think it could be a game-changer
President Trump has touted the drug as a
possible coronavirus treatment but
medical experts are only now testing it
in trials still pharmacists across the
country say it's flying off the shelves
we're seeing prescribers calling into
pharmacies and trying to obtain mass
quantities of hydroxychloroquine or
black Whannell garth reynolds is the
executive director of the illinois
pharmacists association he said a lot of
these prescriptions are being called in
for family members or friends of doctors
i understand why some prescribers
decided to do this but this was an
unethical and selfish action it's not
just in Illinois
pharmacists around the country have
shared similar stories in Florida a
pharmacist told ProPublica one doctor
tried to get 200 tablets of the drug if
I were one of these doctors who was
unnecessarily prescribing
hydroxychloroquine what would you say to
me I completely understand why you're
taking this action you're wanting to
protect your family or yourself but you
and I both took oaths to protect
patients Tancharoen who co-created the
show Marvel's agents of shield and is a
Lupus Foundation of America ambassador
knows she's not alone all of us are in
the same boat so we just don't know how
long this is gonna last CVS Pharmacy
said it's setting quantity limits on the
amount of drug people can get but that's
not going to apply to people like Marisa
who need it for their autoimmune disease
meanwhile the drugs tell us to go
through FDA approval those trials began
Tuesday in New York John do you have any
patients who've tried to get these drugs
Anthony I have they've asked and then
I've explained to them look you don't
want it sitting on your shelves not
being used when people who actually need
it can't use it and I have to say that
I've been very happy to see their
response they get it right away nobody's
fought back and one woman even emailed
me and said she apologized she said I'm
so embarrassed that I even asked thank
you so much for pointing out that this
isn't a time for people to be hoarding
you gotta think about everybody not just
ourselves you're exactly right John I
think most people understand that when
will we know if the drugs are working
you know they're these clinical trials
Gail and that means actually doing it
with a group of
who don't get it and the people of
people a group of people who do get it
and it can take a while before we
actually know the results and for now
this is just anecdotal you've heard
about that word it means we don't really
know if it works some people think that
they've had a patient get better on it
but that doesn't mean that it really
works they could have just been getting
better on their own
yeah it's experimental for coronavirus
but so necessary for people with other
conditions which is important to
remember John thank you very much